ciné vous l'avez connu comme malcom x
vous êtes dessinateur je crois même que
vous avez dessiné pour la revue de mal
comme mon père oui on voir un extrait
alors de ces malcom x différents que
spike lee prêt présentant suivant en
suivant l'avis du leader noir lequel
vous vous intéresse le plus c'est duquel
vous sentez le plus proche ce qui
m'intéresse le plus c'est le seul que
j'ai connu c'est à dire je déconnais en
novembre 64 donc assez tard et je suis
pas d'accord avec ce que vous dites ans
prétend que qu'il était radical pour
tous le début de sa vie qu'il était venu
ouverte à la fin c'est vraiment le
contraire à mon avis il a été aveuglé
toute sa vie par les musulmans et tout
d'un coup il devenait un peu moins bête
et plus plus radical justement plus
socialiste et au moment où il allait
dire ses convictions palme en plus
radicale ibricic terre alors paul lès
dax et c'est pour ça que les mais c'est
pour ça que je le respectais beaucoup
j'ai il est venu un jour à la maison a
mené par carlos moore
c'était un cubain africains d'origine
africaine mais qui vivaient avec et qui
était qui avait quitté cuba pour des
raisons acide de racisme d'ailleurs et
qui était parti le rejoindre là-bas et
un jour il m'a appelé en me disant qu'un
je suis devenu je travaille maintenant
avec malcolm je vais te l'amener chez
toi parce qu'il doit faire une
conférence ce soir à la mutualité
et il n'a pas envie de descendre dans un
hôtel il veut aller chez des copains
parce qu'il n'a pas confiance il était
déjà peu près sûr de se faire flinguer
il savait que sa vie était en danger
donc il est venu je suis allé le
chercher avec carlos iii à orly les deux
schémas il a passé 12 heures on a bu du
rhum cubain
ça suffit
et il m'a dit et imagine que si je
prononçais mot socialiste ou trotskistes
ou marxiste les gens n'accepterait pas
de bars de montréal situé au frais du
whisky avec une tête de mort comme comme
étiquette donc bon je continue à
prétendre être musulman mais pas chez je
peux pas faire autrement et pour
contrecarrer la la la religion
catholique qui a complètement à betty
les noirs américains la seule le seul
moyen de lutter c'est de trouver une
autre religion aussi forte au moins qui
donc j'ai pas tellement le choix
et surtout crois moi je suis pas
musulman en tout cas je ne suis plus
voilà